the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire video
as you all know variety and
entertainment weekly recently announced
hbo wants to make more game of thrones
successor shows
they're already working on house of the
dragon as we speak but they're also
considering a series about the
adventures of dunkin
egg as well as a series about robert's
rebellion
since game of thrones was so successful
hbo hopes they can make their own
cinematic universe out of george r
martin's amazing creation
i've said this before and i will say it
again i'll watch just about anything
that's adapted from a song of ice and
fire
the thought that there could be even
more game of thrones successor shows has
me very excited
i recently made a video about some of
the things we will see in house of the
dragon
in this video i want to go over some of
the things we could see in a show about
robert's rebellion
if hbo does decide to move forward with
this show
it should be set roughly 17 years before
the events of game of thrones
now i know a lot of you still haven't
read the book so i will show you what it
says about the events surrounding
robert's rebellion in george
r martin's book the world of ice and
fire i believe the very first season of
robert's rebellion would be set during
the year 281 ac
which is also known as the year of the
fall spring
this was when winter had held the land
and its icy grip for a few years
however the snows were melting the woods
were getting greener
and the days were growing longer the
white ravens of the citadel had not yet
flown
but there were those in old town who
believed the winter's end was almost
here
as the warm winds blew from the south
lords and knights from throughout the
seven kingdoms made their way to
harrenhal to compete in lord wendt's
great tournament
on the shore of the god's eye now i
think almost all of us fans were hoping
we would get to see this in game of
thrones during a flashback scene
unfortunately that never happened but if
we get a show about robert's rebellion
then i believe
we would almost be guaranteed to see
this this really was an incredible
moment in westerosi history
so many different characters were there
that day it would be absolutely amazing
to see this get brought to life on the
screen
now i'm sure most of you already know
rhaegar and lyanna were here
because this is when rhaegar hands her
the blue winter roses right in front of
his very own wife
but a lot of other iconic characters
were here like ned stark
helen reed barristan selmi jaime
lannister
sir arthur dain the mad king robert
baratheon ashara
dane benjen stark and so many more
we do know a great deal about what
happened at harrenhal
yet there is much and more that we shall
never know for even while the greatest
knights of the seven kingdoms divide in
the lists
other and more dangerous games were
being played in the halls of black
herons accursed castle
as well as the pavilions of the lords
assembled
many of these accounts have grown up
around lord wentz tournament
stories of conspiracies and betrayals
rebellions and
infidelities secrets and mysteries
almost all of it is conjecture
we don't exactly know what's real or not
the truth is only known to a few
some of whom are already dead what we do
know is the tournament was first
announced by walter wendt
lord of harrenhal late in the year 280
ac
not long after a visit from his younger
brother sir oswald went
who was the night of the kingsguard this
was said to be an event of unrivaled
magnificence
4 lord rent was offering prizes thrice
as large as those given at the great
king's landing tourney of 272 ac
hosted by lord tywin lannister in
celebration of the mad king's
decade-long reign upon the iron throne
there were those who saw this simply as
an attempt by lord wendt to outdo the
former hand
and demonstrate the wealth and splendor
of his house
there were those however who believed
this was no more than a ruse
and lord went no more than a cat's ball
basically what this means is
lord wendt did not have the kind of
money you would need to be able to do
this
therefore someone else must have been
funding the event at harrenhal
now there is no shred of evidence that
such a shadow host ever existed
but the notion was widely believed and
is still believed till this day
but if indeed there was someone working
in the shadows
who was he and why did he choose to keep
his role a secret
there have been rumors of a dozen
different names over the years but only
one of them seems to be interesting
and that is the one and only rhaegar
targaryen
now if this is true it was rhaegar who
urged lord walter wendt to hold the
tourney at harrenhal
rhaegar provided wendt with gold
sufficient for splendid prizes
in order to bring as many lords and
knights to harrenhal as he could
it's said that rhaegar didn't do all of
this because he cared about competing in
all of the different events
his goal was to gather the great lords
of the realm together
and what amounted to an informal great
council
in order to discuss ways and means of
dealing with the madness of his father
king aerys ii also known as the mad king
if indeed this was the reason behind the
torny it was a perilous game that
rhaegar targaryen was playing
though few doubted that king aerys had
taken leave of his senses
many still had good reason to oppose his
removal from the iron throne
there were those who had become rich
ever since the mad king set on the iron
throne
and they knew they could lose it all if
rhaegar ever did succeed at
ending his father's reign now we all
know the mad king could be savagely
cruel
as you all know he is famously known for
burning his enemies alive
but he could also be extravagant
showering those who made him happy with
honors
offices and even lands of their own the
lords who surrounded king aerys had
gained much and more from the king's
madness
and eagerly seized upon any opportunity
to speak ill of rhaegar
and inflame the father's suspicions of
the son
those among the mad king supporters were
three lords of his small council
carlton chelstead master of coin lou
carey's velaryon
master of ships and simon staunton
master of laws the eunuch varus master
of whisperers
and wisdom resort grand maester of the
guild of alchemists
also enjoyed the king's trust now
rhaegar's support came from the younger
men at court
including lord john connington sir miles
mooton of maidenpool
and sir richard longmouth the dornishmen
who had come to court with princess
elia were in rhaegar's confidence as
well most notably
lou and martell elia's uncle and a sworn
brother of the kingsguard
however the most formidable of all
rhaegar's friends and allies in king's
landing was shirley sir arthur dane
the sword of the morning to grand
maester pycelle in lord
owen merriweather the king's hand fell
the difficult task of keeping the peace
between these factions even as their
rivalry grew
ever more venomous in a letter to the
citadel the grand maester wrote that the
divisions within the red keep
reminded him uncomfortably of the
situation before the dance of dragons
when the hostility between queen alicent
and princess rhaenyra had split the
realm in half
to a grievous cost a similarly blood
conflict might await the seven kingdoms
once again
he warned unless some accord could be
reached that would satisfy both rhaegar
supporters
and the kings now if any evidence of
rhaegar conspiring against his father
fell into the hands of the king's
supporters they most certainly would
have used it to bring about rhaegar's
downfall
indeed certain of the king's men had
even gone so far as to suggest that king
aerys should disinherit his disloyal son
and name his younger brother heir to the
iron throne in his
deed viserys targaryen was but seven
years of age
and his eventual ascension would
certainly mean a regency
wherein they themselves would rule as
regents
in such a climate it was scarce
surprising that lord wendt's great
tournament excited much suspicion
lord chelstead urged his grace to forbid
it
and lord staunton went even further
suggesting a prohibition against all
future attorneys
such events were widely popular with the
commons however
and one lord meriwether warned king
aerys that forbidding the tournament
would only serve to make him even more
unpopular
the king chose another course and he
announced that his intentions were to
attend
it would mark the first occasion that
aerys had left the safety of the red
keep since the defiance of duskendale
no doubt his grace reasoned that his
enemies would not dare conspire against
him
under his very nose the grand maester
tells us that king aerys hoped that his
presence at such a grand event would
help him win back the love of his own
people
if that was his intent it was a grievous
miscalculation
while his attendance made the harrenhal
tourney even grander
and more prestigious than it already was
drawing lords and nights from every
corner of the realm
many of those who came were shocked and
appalled when they saw what had become
of their monarch
his long yellow fingernails messy beard
and ropes of unwashed matted hair
made the extent of the king's madness
obvious to all nor was his behavior that
of a sane man
ferraris could go from mirth to
melancholy in the blink of an eye
and the many accounts written of
harrenhal speak of his hysterical
laughter
long silence bouts of weeping and sudden
rage
now talk about an emotional
rollercoaster above all
king aerys was suspicious he was
suspicious of his own son and
heir rhaegar suspicious of his host lord
wendt
suspicious of every lord and knight who
had come to harrenhal to compete
and even more suspicious of those who
chose to be absent
the most notable of whom was his former
hand tywin lannister lord of casterly
rock
at the opening ceremonies the mad king
made a great show of sir jamie
lannister's honors as the sworn brother
of his kingsguard
the young knight set his vows before the
royal pavilion
kneeling on the green grass and his
white armor as half the lords of the
realm looked on
when sir gerald hightower raised him up
and clasped the white cloak about his
shoulders
a loud cheer went up from the crowd for
sir jaime was much admired for his
courage
gallantry and skill with the sword
especially in the westerlands
now although tywin lannister did not
attend himself
dozens of his lord's bannermen and
hundreds of knights were on hand
and they raised a loud and lusty cheer
for the newest
and youngest sworn brother of the
kingsguard the king did seem happy
in his madness we are told his grace
believed they were cheering for him
now shortly after naming sergey to his
kingsguard
aerys started having doubts about his
new guard the king had seized upon
the notion of bringing sir jamie into
the kingsguard as a way of humbling his
old friend
and former hand tywin lannister he knew
jaime was his golden child
so as a way to slight him he took away
his heir
since members of the kingsguard can no
longer take wives or father children
only now belatedly did his grace come to
the realization that he would henceforce
have lord tywin's son beside him day and
night with a sword at his side
the thought frightened him so badly that
he could hardly eat at the night's feast
the grand maester of owls accordingly
king aerys summoned sir jamie to attend
him while squatting over his chamber pot
some say
but that ugly little detail may have
been a later addition to the story
and he commanded him to return to king's
landing to guard queen raela
and viserys who had not accompanied his
grace to harrenhal
the lord commander sir gerald hightower
offered to go in jaime's stead
but heiress refused him for the young
knight who had no doubt hoped to
distinguish himself in the tourney
this abrupt exile came as a bitter
disappointment
nonetheless sir jaime remained true to
his vows
he set off for the red keep at once and
played enough for the role in the events
at harrenhal
for seven days the finest knights and
noblest lords of the seven kingdoms
contended with lance and sword
in the fields beneath the walls of
harrenhal at night
victors and vanquished alike repaired to
the castle's cavernous hall of a hundred
hearts for feasting and celebration
many songs and stories are told of those
days and nights besides the god's eye
some of them are even true there are a
few incidents we must bring to light
however
for they would prove to have grave
consequences
the first was the appearance of a
mystery knight a slight young man
an ill-fitting armor whose device was a
carved white werewood tree
that had its own face to which appeared
to be laughing
so the night of the laughing tree as
this challenger was called
unhorsed three men in succession to the
delight of the common folk
the mad king aerys was not a man to take
joy and mysteries however
he became convinced that the werewolf on
the mystery knight's shield was laughing
at him
and he had made up his mind that the
mystery knight was sir jaime lannister
his newest kingsguard had to fight him
in return to the tourney
he told every man who would listen he
was so furious
he commanded his own knights to defeat
the night of the laughing tree when the
joust resumed on the next morning
so that he might unmask this mystery man
but the mystery knight vanished during
the night never to be seen
again this made the mad king even matter
certain that someone close to him had
given warning to the traitor who will
not show his face
rhaegar emerged as the ultimate victor
at the end of the competition
he surprised everyone when he defeated
every foe that he faced
including four different knights of the
kingsguard in the final match
he was even able to unhorse the great
sarbaristan selmy
generally regarded as the finest
alliance and all of the seven
kingdoms the cheers of the crowd were
said to be deafening
but his own father king aerys did not
join in the celebration of his son
you'd think he would be happy about his
son and heir
skill at arms but his grace saw that as
a threat
but that's not all oh no no no no no
when rhaegar named the lyanna stark the
queen of love and beauty
setting a garland of blue roses in her
lap the lords gathered around the king
declared that was even more
evidence of his deceitfulness why else
would rhaegar have given insult to his
own wife
elia martell of dorne unless it was to
help him gain the iron throne
the crowning of the stark girl who was
by all reports a wild and boyish young
thing with none of elia martell's
delicate beauty
could only have meant to win the
allegiance of winterfell to rhaegar's
cause
yet if this were true why did lady
lyanna's brother
seem so distraught at the honor rhaegar
had bestowed upon her
brandon stark the heir to winterfell had
to be restrained from confronting
rhaegar
at what he took as a slight upon his
sister's honor
for lyanna stark had long been betrothed
to robert baratheon
now eddard stark wasn't as upset as his
brother brandon was
but he wasn't exactly happy either as
for robert baratheon himself
some say he laughed at the gesture
saying that rhaegar had done
no more than pay liana her do but those
who knew him better say the young lord
brooded on the insult
and that his heart hardened toward
rhaegar from that day
forth and well it might for with that
simple garland of blue roses
rhaegar targaryen had begun the dance
that would rip
the seven kingdoms apart it also brought
about his own death
and thousands more and it led to robert
baratheon sitting upon the iron throne
[Music]
[Music]
you